Britain's military intelligence
believes that Russian attacks
are gaining more traction in backing.
The Ukrainian military released
this video
showing troops fighting House-to-house
in damaged buildings.
But British intelligence says
it believes the Russian troops
have, quote,
regained some momentum there
and have likely advanced
into the city center.
Meanwhile, Ukrainian
officials are making it clear
that they're not ready
for any territorial concessions
to Russia.
That appears
to walk back remarks
from a top presidential adviser
who suggested to the Financial Times
that Crimea could be up for negotiation.
The Ukrainian aircraft producer
wants to get the world's largest plane
back in the sky.
Antonov 25 was one of a kind
which Ukraine built in the 1980s.
It was an engineering marvel
before it was destroyed
in the early days of the war.
But as David McKenzie reports, Ukraine is
not ready to give up on it.
The first hours of the war,
Russian elite forces
descending on
just the more airport outside Kiev,
their intended launch pad to the capital
It didn't work out.
Ukrainian forces
famously pushed the Russians back
and they made a discovery at them.
All the pride of Ukraine.
The remarkable
And two to five or Maria cargo plane
gutted in the fighting.
You know, it was feeling like
you are a part of something great.
It's the first time
pilot Yevgeny Kaczynski has come back.
Yevgeny coming back here,
it must be quite hard for you
What's the emotion like?
It's very, very hard to be here
and to see all this station's
destroyed plane destroyed hangars.
It's quite hard to see.
The Ukrainian
Antonov company
says it wants to rebuild this
one of a kind giant.
No matter what it takes
or not, bring more.
Designer Valeria
Castillo says
they've already retrieved
much of what they can use.
You can feel the extraordinary size
of this plane inside the fuselage.
The Maria was the heaviest plane
in the world
and it could carry up to 250 tons inside
or even on top,
designed to
transport the Soviet
era Buren spacecraft.
The Antonov company refurbished the Maria
multiple times with six TurboFan engines,
each with more than £50,000 of thrust
and a 32 wheel landing gear system.
The Maria was a marvel, an outsized hit
with plane
spotters and aviation enthusiasts.
When you were flying this plane,
so many people wanted to take photos
of it, follow it.
What was that like?
I was feeling a
great responsibility,
not only to operate this plane
properly, correctly,
but it was also a great responsibility
because you're attracting
a lot of attention.
A few days after,
you can open the YouTube and see
all what have done.
But to put Maria back in the sky,
the Antonov company says
it could cost nearly $1,000,000,000
and take years.
But for Ukrainians,
it's a point of pride.
David McKenzie CNN, Kiev, Ukraine.
A Moscow
court has set a
date to hear
an appeal of the arrest
of an American journalist.
That is according to Russian state media,
which cited the court
Evan Gersh
Kovic is a reporter
for The Wall Street Journal,
and he faces up to 20 years
in prison on espionage charges.
The Journal vehemently denied
the charges, calling it a quote,
vicious affront to a free press.
The court will hear the appeal on April
the 18th.
His arrest marks
a significant escalation
of both Moscow's tensions with the U.S.
and its campaign
against foreign news media.